[Music]
[Applause]
why would i betray you we all have our
secrets we just didn't get to yours yet
hello and welcome to behind the movie
for no time to die I am your host Novak
Niki Novak today we are going to be
jumping in and talking all things
double-oh-seven and I have two very
special people helping me out who are
already laughing at me first he is a
comedy legend he is a Bond super fan and
he has been training so hard he actually
might announce today he's the next James
Bond mr. J Washington leave that I did
not know was happening I'm happy to be
here comedy legend Wow thank you my
grandmother must have called you
appreciated oh thank you I'm glad to be
here with y'all and this guy you know
him you love him he is the managing
editor at Fandango he has never shaken
or stirred he is the coolest guy I know
and the undisputed king of Twitter James
Barr needs to wear more hats yes yes he
does alright guys so in addition to
answering all of your burning questions
about the upcoming movie no time to die
we're also going to be counting down the
best bond of all time and guess what it
was ranked by you the fans so it is all
on you and we're gonna jump right in at
number 6 don't look at the prompter do
you know who it is you know we're
talking about Internet fans so it's like
it could be up and down I would say some
for some Sean Connery likes to make
people man likes to make people mad so
it's reverse psychology yes man I'm
gonna say Lazenby cuz he only did one
film what do you think about please beat
being number six I mean he made one Bond
movie it's kind of fair that he should
be now they're like hanging out you know
say nobody really got to know you soon
as you do a film you do a Bond film will
you wait on the next ones you wait on
the subsequent ones if you do one you
like oh so that's it you're done you
finish you go yeah it's a great film
though on Her Majesty's Secret Service
and I think what a lot of people don't
realize about that film is just how much
it inspired Daniel Craig's version of
bond you know Lazenby is a bond that's
vulnerable he falls in love
love that he has dyes and he has to deal
with that and come to terms with that
which we kind of saw from Casino Royale
so I think a lot of those old sort of
you know that those old Bond movies are
really inspiring what people are
watching today and so go back if you
haven't seen the Lazenby movie go back
and watch it okay so we're gonna jump in
with my first question to you guys this
is reported to be one of the most
expensive Bond movies ever made reported
250 million dollar budget which is
insane is this going to be the best
movie of all the best Bond movie of all
time
Eric what do you say I better be good
that a billion dollars a good me just be
good I you know what I'm a big fan of
this film's director Cary Fukunaga I
think he does great work and I think
he's going to be a great addition to the
lexicon of Bond directors
I think this stunts look good I think
they're putting bharden interesting
scenarios I think it's Daniel Craig's
last Bond so they can really kind of
push it and take risks with it and so
yeah I think it's gonna be good I think
will it be among the best of Daniel
Craig's films I would say yes it seems
like with Daniel Craig every other Bond
film is really good and the ones is
between aren't so good and so I think we
are now two away from Skyfall which was
the last I think really great Bond movie
and so I think this one will be good I
think it literally all depends on how
this film ends cuz you can put this
magnificent budget behind him we see
these cars these Drive scenes these
explosions all of this like you said the
different scenes and the scenarios you
put Bond in but the way this film wraps
up because it being Daniel Craig's last
film and we know it it'd be a different
story if we didn't know if it was all of
a sudden we have this movie and then
afterwards he announces I'm done his
bond but we know this is before he said
he said sometimes they're just I think
they're tired and they say that when
they finish filming the last one and
then you give him a couple years and
they go Ameren kinda ready oh yeah I
mean he wrote what he's broke his ankle
messed his leg up or something like that
while filming this and so but now he's
able to be more laid-back with the
knives out franchise so now he can go to
that this depends on how this movie ends
how you wrap this up do you conclude him
as bond actually dying or just going
away do you
that mantle being taken over and things
like that it's that's what's gonna be
the thing that solidifies okay we're
gonna get to where this bond where bond
is going but first I want to ask you
guys
Phoebe Waller bridge was brought in as a
writer for this yes applause for Phoebe
real are killing Eve you know we know of
course we know she's great with fleabag
what do you think why did they bring her
on what is she going to bring to this
film I think there's multiple women that
they're juggling in this film between
leshawna Lynch and Ana de Armas and Lisa
Dow and so I feel like they brought her
in because she's really great at writing
complex female characters you know
people who are are funny and a little
you know adventurous and you know a
little badass and maybe there's mystery
behind them and I think she is really
great and maybe one of the best right
now at writing those kind of complex
complicated characters and so I think
she is going to bring a really great
freshness to the bond films and so I
can't wait to see and I think we'll be
able to see what her contributions are
as the story unfolds I have a question
for you because you know I love Daniel
Craig and knives out I love the humor
they brought to it even though he played
the character so straight do you think
Phoebe's gonna write more human exactly
what she's gonna do because everything
you just said is already there with the
majority of these characters if you look
at it look at Naomi Harris's Moneypenny
like you didn't know she was gonna be
Moneypenny till the end when she finally
said my name is Eve Moneypenny
there's different things you get about
it you got the complexities characters
but there's gonna be way more humor than
we've ever seen in any of these other
films like we see little jabs and little
jokes here and there but it'll be
layered in more and like you said these
female characters so they definitely
give in some of the moments you'd be
like oh she's being flooding right now
when she's blowing something up so I
think we're gonna get that out of it
it's gonna be a great thing I want some
of those Roger Moore one-liners coming
back okay we're gonna go back to our
countdown of the best bond of all time
voted by you coming in at number 5
Timothy Dalton was at number 5 we think
first I'm gonna we had some comments on
Facebook Nathan said I like Timothy
Dalton quite a bit maybe even more than
Craig that's huge maybe it was his messy
hair or the way he says bond James Bond
without
taking a pause but I thought he was
pretty tough what do you guys think I
like Timothy Dalton that's why I was so
happy when he was cast as the chief and
Doom Patrol I loved his mom you like yo
you get this bond as a comic-book
character now and so I loved what he
brought in those films so yeah five slow
for me but I get it I'm a Dalton fan
yeah I mean he only did a couple of Bond
films and he was coming after Roger
Moore who was a little bit more comical
and goofy and so I think people were
looking for a Dalton who brought the
grittiness back to by you know he was
rough around the edges he was kind of
didn't want to be body was closer to
what Ian Fleming's version of Bond was
in those books and so I think that's why
people like him but yes again it makes
sense for the survey because he you know
he's only been in a couple so people
didn't really get used to him but check
out the living daylights I think that's
my favorite it's real quick it seems
like the way the fans are voting on it's
like if you need a minimal amount of
numbers you go from the bottom to the
top that's how that's getting raised
about you did least five things you were
higher the numbers you know true true I
can't wait to see the way the rest of it
pans out so we talked a little bit about
this already but is this Daniel Craig's
Lascaux is he is he coming back again
what do you think Eric I think this is
it for him yeah I think he's made it
pretty clear that he's done with this
character this is a character I mean
he's been playing this character for
like a decade you know and I think he
wants to move on and I think we're ready
for him to move on we're ready for the
next chapter in the James Bond saga
whatever that may be and so I think this
will be his last one and I hope they
make it memorable I hope they do
something with this performance that
we've never seen from bond I don't know
if they would kill him I don't know if
they would kill again I think you have
well they say an emotional conclusion I
mean to me that means there's it's may
happen because we've already seen that I
go away and retire I live this beautiful
life you unfortunately in a sounds more
but you have to see him die but you have
to see him die in a way that has all
these stakes behind it it can't just be
a oh that was very uninspiring you know
and you know uneventful where it's a
death and you're just like oh he just
got shot in the chest real quick that
was it
is it you want to have something behind
it when you see you are almost in tears
in the theater well I think what would
be great is if they sort of mirrored the
Casino Royale so instead of him you know
looking over this love that just died
it's the person that he loved like alia
Sadao yes looking over him as he dies
and so it might be good if they mirrored
that you know finale of Casino Royale
and that would tie all of the films
together because we've never had one of
his loves mourning because you have to
see him die because we know from Skyfall
does he ever really die I mean when he
fell off the tree and I thought that was
it okay back to your favorite blondes
coming in at number four Roger Moore I
love him Lana says I always liked Roger
Moore very cool very slow very
sophisticated I agree what do you guys
think about him
he's the man a lot of people grew up
with James Bond with me so yeah a lot of
people were like you know Roger Moore is
my dude but number stuff so most people
he's not number four he's number one
yeah but that's how he is he's the
person introduced or you know this is
Roger Moore this is that bond James Bond
yeah he was funny he was he was a
funnier bond the films were funnier they
were lighter my first two Bond films
warheads were Octopussy and a view to a
kill so I I definitely think you know
his bond went to outer space and
Moonraker at the time and so I think
they really kind of took liberties with
his body and said what code James Bond
be if we kind of went a little bit
lighter as doing that a little crazier
my favorites I really liked him okay
let's talk about villains for a second
when I heard rami malek was gonna be the
villain in this movie I was like this is
the best announcement I think I've ever
heard in film history what do you think
he's gonna bring to this and is he gonna
be the best Bond villain of all time
that's Bond villain his heart so I had a
couple of theories I was like maybe he
could be silvers kid that we didn't know
he might have had some connection mr.
white but everybody's rumor and he's the
next Doctor know which I think would be
perfect because you'll have a little
spin up because you see the
turns on his face but you know doctor no
had prosthetic hands and maybe at some
point in the film he'll have those
prosthetic hands so I'm thinking he
might be doctor no because doctor no
also has a connection to Spectre which
we know is still going on so that can
open up a world in the game you can have
him going forward you know you get rid
of Daniel Craig not saying get rid of
but you remove Daniel Craig for them
collision now you have Romney Malik as
this villain to carry over for maybe one
or two films yeah it's almost like
you're resetting bond in a way and going
all the way back to the beginning and
then kind of rebooting all of those
classic villains you know then they can
bring jaws back and they can you know
start with Romney and I mean Romney is a
terrific actor
he's an Oscar winner now you know and I
think he really brings it you know and I
think Bond villains are maniacal they
want to destroy the world you know and
they could be a little bit cliched and
cookie cutter at times and so I think
you know what does he bring to it what
kind of gravitas does he bring to it and
of course these villains all have
personal connections to bond
what is that connection and how does
that play out throughout the film but I
love the crazy phantom of the opera'
mask that he's wearing and you know
decorate him up any kind of gadgets and
crazy looks that they can give these
Bond villains those are the ones that I
remember the most is when you can look
at them and just instantly they're
iconic and I think Romney could do it
yeah and I think they've teased they've
said well you see how man I call this
this villain is going to be okay back to
the fan poll coming in at number three
for your third favorite bond of all time
Pierce Brosnan
[Applause]
Sexton solving he was meeting people at
the first don't as well
Brosnan but what Brosnan I thought
brought to bond
other than the films you know this was
the rise of digital effects and so I
think these were the first Bond films
that we were like oh wow there there's
more explosions the action sequences are
more elaborate but also Brosnan voiced
the video game you know Goldeneye if you
were a video game player is a
quintessential video game in class again
yeah and I think that helped evolve the
Bond brand was when they went into video
games Brosnan was that voice and I think
a lot of people are endeared to Brosnan
less so for those movies which do not
age well because of some of the things
you mentioned but also because they grew
up playing those video games you can be
the first time I think he was perfect
for that era
okay so Ricard says I think Pierce
Brosnan is old and I was well-balanced
elegant smart dark and badass that
sounds like the wine I drank all right
let's talk music for a second Billy
Eilish was brought on to do the theme
song for this bond but we always know
this is a huge honor but do you think I
mean she's one of the biggest stars and
music stars in the world right now did
they bring her on to sort of get a
younger audience excited about bond
films was that the strategy
she just swept at the Grammy she made a
big splash she got to perform at the
Oscars now she's doing the Bond theme
which again every artist that has done
it from Sam Smith to Adele recently were
top-tier artists all this does is
bringing a younger generation who's like
I'm not about to watch no spy movie but
now you hear Billy I was singing the
theme you're like hey does she have any
other songs in this so that's it's a
smart move it's a power play in a
business move yeah I like Billy I think
I think it's a great and I think to
speak to what you saying they're always
getting artists that are at the top of
their game and no other artist is at
that top like a Billy Eilish right now
and so yeah and I think they're
appealing to it
younger audience but you know it's the
Oscars just did it too they're like can
we borrow Billy eyelids to look cool all
right you guys we are ready for number I
would say number two on the list for the
best bond of all time but guess what it
was a tie which I cannot believe in a
tie and there's only two people left so
yes you guys voted Sean Connery and
Daniel Craig tie my gosh so Dale said
tie for Connery and Craig two very
different bonds but equally great what
do you think about it being a tie and I
also want to know who your favorite
bands of all time work yes I think tie
makes sense yes because I think for
people a lot of people that are watching
this movie kind of grew up with the
Daniel Craig movies but when you think
of James Bond the first person that
comes to your head is Sean Connery
because he started his bond so it really
does make sense as that bookend that
those two guys would come and tie and
breaking that tie for me I would I have
to go with Connery I think Connery
Connery is the best because I think
Connery brought a charisma that Daniel
Craig does not really have as much I
feel like Daniel Craig is a little bit
more like the Timothy Dalton bonds which
is good but I like that humor and that's
what we were saying before I hope they
bring a little bit more humor back and
people like that yeah I feel I feel like
with the with the humor and the charisma
that you say for Craig he doesn't have
it because he's so grounded in real life
he's so much more like that dog he's so
this is this is everything is real these
stakes are real it doesn't feel like
you're watching a movie you feel like
you're watching a man go through
something in real life when you watch
Daniel Craig and again going from Casino
Royale watching the deaf Vesper and
every woman he's been involved with from
Quantum of Solace Skyfall Spectre and
then to see him now being loved with
Madeline and she was like I just can't
do this you just won't let go you know
like to see him being hard
broken but still have to work it's you
know that's the thing about Craig for me
again I understand the tie completely I
do but I think the charisma is a
different level where you say from
Connery to Craig yeah I'm gonna break
the tie between the two of you and
[Applause]
although I do really love Daniel Craig
with Connery to me was just like the
quintessential and that's what I love
it's what he just had that charisma and
he had that you just never knew what's
gonna happen but he was able to bring
the mystery what I love though is that
Sean Connery has said how much he loves
Daniel Craig as Bond said he's given him
the problems that's the thing is he's
the international man of mystery you
know he can blend into any kind of
situation Sean Connery was that Daniel
Craig's bit of a grump a basic North
Face jacket he blends in everywhere
Starbucks in West Hollywood in a North
Face jacket he does not blend it all
right what do you guys think though
let's talk about the future of bond
obviously I think we pretty much think
this is going to be Daniel Craig's last
Bond where do you see the franchise
going and here's the burning question
that people have been speculating are
they going to introduce the next
double-oh-seven in no time to die I
think they have to because again we're
leaving with Craig leaving that leaves a
big gap and I don't think everybody
wants to play the wait game of who's
gonna be the next double oh seven when
are they gonna finally announce it if
you announced it in this film then you
can have the whole James Bond will
return or double-oh-seven will return
and that's being if leshawna Lynch
because I believe she's double over for
something
yeah she's double for but we you know
everybody's speculating that it could be
a woman now either Estelle bit first was
rumoured to be it but he was like I
don't want to be known as the black
James Bond I just want to be known as
James Bond
so whoever takes that mantle has a heavy
shoes to fill but also I do hope they go
in a completely different direction just
to make the Internet mad it's a boy if
you pick a woman the internet loses its
mind off jump if you pick anyone else
but the typical James Bond prototype the
internet loses its mark
but the thing of the internet lose this
mind is they forget that a world of
possibilities are now open more than
what you've seen before in throughout
the pond history he doesn't take away
the legacy of the character and what
this character is known for it just adds
an extra layer an extra element to it so
who's your choice who would you like it
to be what do you how are you gonna make
the Internet mad here I give it to
leshawna Lynch with no problem because
if you want to change things up have em
be woman have the have Q be a woman you
have Moneypenny steel and then make bond
a woman it changes the dichotomy of what
mi6 is but it keeps the same Flair going
and if you brought Phoebe while a bridge
aren't for a reason now you're trying to
see what she can build in this universe
and you go forward with it ya know I
think it makes I think it makes a lot of
sense I mean I I what I want to see is I
want to see them in this storyline I
don't want this storyline
to continue I kind of want to go back to
the one offs I would love to see someone
off Bond movies where you get somebody
like the safty brothers to do a one-off
Bond movie you know and to see what it
looks through it through the lens I'm
watching a lot of uncut gems right now
I'm not saying not saying Adam Sandler
should be the next Bond but I'm saying
I'd love to see what they love The
Sandman but that would be a reach but I
do think you know I would love to see
them takes you know like hot director
and just but just one movie and just
one-off bonds you know but we're really
into these interconnected storylines
right now and whether who should be the
next Bond
I don't know I'm I am of the opinion
where it's like let the next James Bond
movie maybe there's like more than one
James Bond maybe James Bond isn't an
individual but it's a moniker and maybe
this film kind of tells you about that
you know going all the way back to the
beginning of this conversation the
George Lazenby movie they always say
that movie he breaks the fourth wall and
he's like the other fella never had to
go through this and a lot of people say
he's breaking the fourth wall he's
referring to James Bond but what if in
that moment he's referring to the fact
that there are other James Bond's in the
world so who's saying there
double-oh-seven isn't just a monitor
with James Bond
and what if the next movie there were
five James Bob so you're saying we'll
find out Daniel Craig's real name is
Maurice who's who's with the safty
brothers who are you pairing with the
sappy brothers first one I don't you
know how do we keep hearing Henry Cavill
there's a lot of names that keep getting
fantasy I would throw Rob Pattinson I I
think they're good work yes yes I think
he's crazy I think he's a great actor I
think if you watch good time with with
him and the safdie's yeah I think they
would make the most visceral James Bond
movie do it in real time
it's like bonds on a mission you drop
right in he's got two hours to get from
here to there and that's the movie would
you do a quiz for Christopher McQuarrie
give him what he's missing two paws I
mean but that's the whole thing I think
he's in he's already an impossible mode
and you have to differentiate ourselves
but do that I think go the opposite way
and getting up-and-coming directors that
are hot right now that have a visual
style and tone that is completely
different than what we've raised okay
I'm just gonna throw this out to the
audience who threw out some names real
quick threw out some names shut them out
Charlie Mad Max I'm drawing a blank
anyone else anyone else anyone else
Pat cotton says and we like fast but I
disagree I do not think they should
introduce the bond in this new dojo I
think because as a marketing tactic you
know you can kind of that's how you sell
it that's how you keep people waiting I
could talk about it for another three
years he's the quintessential he's got
the look soif he's got the whole thing
okay all right I would love to keep
talking about this but I think we're out
of time but we want to hear from all of
you guys please leave us a comment let
us know if you think the next
double-oh-seven is gonna be introduced
in this film and if so who you think it
could be also let us know who you think
would make a great double-oh-seven in
the comments a massive thank you Jay
Washington Eric
for joining we're this fabulous audience
and thank you guys for tuning in see you
next time bye
you